oui
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de la grande interview on va
parler des dérives sectaires avec la
crise sanitaire le contexte a été
favorable pour les gourous les
charlatans face à des français isolé en
quête de sens mais c'est aussi la baisse
de vigilance des autorités ces dernières
années qui a permis la prolifération des
mouvements sectaires près d'un demi
million de français elles vivent sous
emprise aujourd'hui gouvernement partis
politiques écoles religion monde de la
finance parfois des villages entiers
c'est toutes les sphères de notre
société qui sont touchés alors pour en
parler on va retrouver les journalistes
jean-louis des nord et timothée de roux
blood rebonjour alors vous publier le
nouveau péril sectaire aux éditions
robert laffont c'est une enquête un état
des lieux finalement sur les dérives les
mouvements sectaires aujourd'hui en
france je le disais on le voit sa touche
toutes les couches de la société dans la
sphère politique les religions ça on le
savait et des villages entiers parfois
on sait plus ou moins on va y revenir
mais votre champ d'action bourreau de
travail c'était quoi qu'est ce qu'on
appelle une dérive sectaire finalement
aujourd'hui timothée de rauglaudre alors
nous notre parti c'était vraiment de
nous appuyer au maximum sur des
témoignages de victimes donc on a retenu
une trentaine et pour pour déterminer
s'il s'agissait ou non de dérives
sectaires on les a passés au crible des
critères de la miviludes qui est
l'organisme gouvernemental chargé de
lutter contre les dérives sectaires et
qui liste dont 15 11 11 indices comme un
faisceau d'indicés qui permettent de
déterminer une emprise sectaire donc on
va pas tous testés ici mais la
déstabilisation mentale la rupture avec
l'entourage les exigences financières
disproportionnées ou les troubles à
l'ordre public qui permettent en fait
non pas de définir ce qu'est une secte
puisque nous on utilise jamais le mot de
secte mais plutôt d'identifier les
comportements qui peuvent être
préjudiciables à l'individu vous parliez
de la miviludes donc celle organisme de
l'état chargé de lutter contre ces
dérives sectaires sais c'est que ça fait
longtemps d'ailleurs que l'état français
a pris en compte cette problématique
c'était même une exception dans le monde
finalement jouer de nos jours une
exception dans le monde c'est un outil
qu'on l'a construit en france qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs alors il ya
un équivalent en belgique mais qui
fonctionne pas la même façon
c'est une exception française
effectivement de surveiller de faire des
dossiers des rapports qui qui font état
du risque sectaire en france de
permettre aux services de l'état de
travailler ensemble à la détection et la
protection des citoyens sur sur ces
questions là donc oui c'est un modèle
typiquement français ce qui avait
lui-même des incidents diplomatiques
vous le raconter dans votre livre en
1999 il me semble c'était une bédouine
qui était ministre des affaires
étrangères c'est bien cela oui
exactement en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que à partir de la moitié des
années 90 les pouvoirs publics se met
vraiment en mouvement sur la question
des dérives sectaires
à la faveur de deux tragédies comme les
pseudos suicide collectif de l'ordre du
temple solaire et donc l'état français
décide de mettre en place un modèle
spécifique avec d'abord un observatoire
puis la mission interministérielle de
lutte contre les sectes devenue
aujourd'hui la neige il y eut donc en
prenant le parti de protéger les
citoyens et de mettre la protection des
citoyens au dessus de la liberté de
croyance finalement et les etats-unis
qui ont en fait parfois soutenues des
mouvements à tendance sectaire sur la
logi par exemple mais également par
exemple l'église de du révérend moon
pendant la guerre froide utilisés pour
lutter contre contre la corée du nord
donc les états unis ont développé une
espèce de diplomatie de défense de la
liberté de croyance ce qui fait que à la
fin des années 90 effectivement le
département d'état donc l'équivalent du
ministère des affaires étrangères
critique ouvertement le gouvernement
français pour avoir mis en place ces
politiques de protection des victimes de
l'emprise sectaire et on s'est rendu
compte par la suite après donc cet
incident diplomatique avec avec
madeleine albright ce qui était en
charge du département d'état à l'époque
que pour pour produire leur rapport
c'est ses administrateurs américains
avaient auditionné les avocats des
témoins de jéhovah et de la scientologie
est effectivement aujourd'hui il ya un
autre son de cloche finalement parce que
quand on lit votre livre on voit que
c'est une vraie problématique
aujourd'hui en france et que l'état ne
met plus les moyens pour pour lutter
contre ces dérives comment est-ce qu'on
lui explique alors n'a plus mis les
moyens nous on apporte une plus tôt un
faisceau d'indicés faisceau
d'explication plutôt qu'une explication
unique et définitive mais c'est vrai que
le phénomène secteur est passé disons un
peu dans l'ombre pendant quelques années
pendant une dizaine d'années aujourd'hui
on le voit avec le fait même du code
vide ou là ces pratiques sont les la
question des dérives sectaires est
revenu en fait dans le débat public et
on voit que après avoir essayé de le
marginaliser la miviludes on a une
reprise en main en tout cas politique de
de l'instrument sans forcément qu'il est
moyen qu'ils soient mis qu'ils soient
mis derrière on remarque aussi vous
voulez raconter qu'il ya une proximité
parfois entre certains membres du
gouvernement même du dernier
gouvernement et puis des mouvements qui
pose question je pense notamment à ces
fameuses écoles dites stener ça
on donne des exemples très concrets le
plus connu c'est celui de l'ancien
ministre de la culture françoise nyssen
directrice des éditions actes sud qui en
fait avant de rejoindre le gouvernement
à monter une école alternative
on donne aussi dans le livre un exemple
un peu moins connus qui est celui de
marc guillaume l'ancien secrétaire
général du gouvernement qui est celui
qui a pris la décision finale de en tout
cas qui a avalisé la décision finale de
rattacher la venue d'auch ministère de
l'intérieur et qui se trouve en fait
avoir accompagné dé des entrepreneurs en
agriculture biodynamique encore une
autre branche de l'anthroposophie pour
une reconnaissance au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco et pour la légion d'honneur
il y avait un quotidien national aussi
qui avait finalement fait un focus sur
ces écoles qui avaient ce plutôt salué
cette pédagogie dont on voit que c'est
ces mouvements là sont sont bien
infiltré jeudi dans l'assaut des quatre
l'anthroposophie particulièrement il ya
une stratégie qui consiste à avancer
masqué qui est qu une stratégie qu'on
documents entre nous qu'on montre en
fait comme timothée parle de l'éducation
la pédagogie steiner waldorf
quand on parle de l'agriculture en
biodynamie en fait les gens dans le
tente pas les fondements ésotérique qui
se trouve derrière ces deux pans de
l'anthroposophie en fait les gens qui
mettent leurs enfants en école steiner
où certains agriculteurs qui se lancent
en agriculture biodynamique où vous
quand vous allez acheter du vin ou au
supermarché vous prenez un vol de
dynamique pensant qu'il s'agit de vins
bio plus plus en maintenant pour pour
faire les choses progressent tout
simplement en fait vous ne savez pas que
à l'origine de ces et de ces deux
courants là il y à un ésotérisme
l'occultiste du début du xxème siècle
qui n'avait ni compétences emplois dans
l'éducation des enfants des compétences
particulières en tout cas ni en
agriculture timothée rappelle dans l
ouvrage que je taille mais on n'avait
jamais mis les pieds dans un champ de sa
vie avant de faire cette conférence aux
agriculteurs qu'il donne et qui va
donner des du dynamique cette stratégie
là on l'a documente très bien dans
l'entrepôt sophie il ya d'autres groupes
qui qui qui avance masqué mais c'est
vrai que ce que réussit à faire le
l'entrepôt zoophiles en france est assez
assez surprenant et c'est vrai que
derrière il ya un témoignage
bouleversant d'une mère de famille qui a
mis son fils qui étaient en situation de
handicap et qui a vécu un calvaire
finalement oui c'est un des témoignages
qui nous ont le plus marqué je pense
donc c'est on l'appelle carla dans le
livre donc c'est une mère de famille de
deux classes aisées qui met son fils
disent pratiquer 10 graphique dans une
école alternative
pour le sortir de l'éducation nationale
où ils avaient été maltraités par les
institutrices et donc elle pense
découvrir une pédagogie
bienveillante qui fait vraiment
attention à l'enfant tant en tant
qu'individu qui donne une place
importante au contact avec la nature aux
activités artistiques etc et il ya cette
dimension en partie mais peu à peu elle
découvre toute une dimension ésotérique
dont elle n'avait pas du tout été
informé à l'origine donc les fameuses
paroles de steiner le matin qui
ressemble en fait à des des prières les
fêtes comme la spirale de l'avant ou où
les enfants sont invités à tourner
autour d'une spirale faites de branches
de sapin plongée dans l'obscurité avec
des bougies pour retrouver leur vrai moi
et beaucoup plus grave que ça elle se
rend compte petit à petit que son fils
se fait maltraiter donc physiquement par
les autres enfants de l'école se fait
traiter de porc par les parents parce
que ils n'arrivent pas à manger
correctement et en dise pratique il sera
même violentée par un professeur de
l'école est en fête
car la part de d'impuissance au paradis
c'est à dire elle se retrouve dans une
espèce de cocon protecteur mais dans
lequel est là elle n'a aucun aucune
latitude d'action et elle cherche
pendant des mois des années des
explications pourquoi on pourquoi on
laisse faire ces violences et un jour
elle reçoit la fondatrice de l'école
chez elle très bienveillante très douces
en apparence et qui lui dit si si ton
fils ce fait se fait frapper et si les
handicapés c'est parce qu'il a commis
une faute dans une vie antérieure et en
fait cessé ses justifications exotérique
de violence envers les enfants on les
retrouve dans d'autres écoles où on va
utiliser des notion de karma d'ordre
cosmique la récréation est censé
reproduire l'ordre cosmique donc il ne
faut pas la perturber ce qui conduit à
ne pas surveiller souvent les cours de
récréation
et donc on a une illustration assez
assez flagrante de ce que ce que cette
pédagogie supposé alternative couvre
deux de violences a oui là il est à ces
dérives là je dirais plus classiques
basés vous disiez sur l'ésotérisme et il
ya un autre terrain de jeu pour les
gourous qu'on a découvert alors
notamment avec la crise sanitaire 1 cc
internet oui alors c'est ce qu'ont
documente aussi dans notre travail nous
on s'est intéressé à ce qu'on appelle
donc pour le livre le nouveau péril
sectaire donc on s'est aussi intéressé à
la mutation du phénomène sectaire alors
il ya ce phénomène qui est assez
intéressant mais bon qui est finalement
assez logique c'est que les gourous
comme beaucoup d'autres se sont
intéressés pourront investir internet
comme un nouveau de terrain de
recrutement et un nouveau terrain
d'emprise ça en documenté effectivement
dans le livre mais il ya aussi et aussi
sa phénomène qui en fait montre qu' on
aime de moins on est moins ceux des jo
de mystique moins religieuse comme comme
on peut et on pouvait la voir dans les
années 70-80 que sur des phénomènes qui
vont concerner la santé ou
l'alimentation et la crise du coc vide à
renforcer en fait cette nouvelle porte
d'entrée dans les dérives sectaires ou
des goûts vous plutôt parler de
vaccination plutôt parler d'alimentation
plutôt parler de guérison au lieu
d'aller directement sur un terrain qui
sera un terrain religieux ou mystique et
pourtant quand on creuse un peu et on le
fait notamment sûr qu'elle est mauvaise
dans notre travail on se rend compte de
la dimension mystique elle n'est jamais
très loin alors qu'elle est mauvaise
très rapidement c'est celui qu'on a
surnommé l'apôtre du crudivorisme notre
notre livre c'est quelqu'un qui est
travailler sur la question des régimes
de la régénération qui fait croire aux
gens quand avec nouvelles alimentations
un certain mode de vie on ne tombera
jamais malade que la médecine se trompe
que la maladie n'existe pas et en fait
derrière ce discours là on retrouve il
le dit lui même dans des vidéos on
retrouve des disques des discours
mystique ou qu'elles s'adressent
explique que c'est bien dieu qui parle
par sa bouche et qu'il est inspiré par
des forces mystiques donc la question
mais c'est qu'elle est juste caché
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs un nouveau vernis
qui est un vernis de l'alimentation de
la santé de la défiance envers big
pharma ou les médecins traditionnels et
1 et un discours qui marche bien dans la
sphère qu'on appelle anti-vaccins
aujourd'hui un absolument en fait bon on
dit on rattache évidemment pas
l'ensemble des personnes anti vaccins a
admis van ce secteur en tout cas c'est
une cible pour ses gourous voilà en fait
ce qu'on documente qui est rarement
mentionnée dans les médias qui vont
plutôt essayer de voir l'influencé de
l'extrême droite de l'extrême gauche des
mouvements libertaires et c'est en
vérité ce qui est beaucoup plus
important pour nous c'est que on
retrouve par exemple dans les dernières
manifestations anti vaccin contre le coc
vides certains éléments qui se
rattachent à à des mouvements à tendance
sectaire qui historiquement sont opposés
à toute vaccination donc on donne
notamment deux exemples qui sont celui
de de la mouvance catholiques
intégristes autour de la fraternité
saint-pie 10 et 2 de son émanation
politique si vite à ce qu'on retrouve
dans les manifestations avec le le
drapeau du coeur sacré de jésus etc et
de l'autre côté des gens plutôt qui se
rattache plutôt à l'écologie newedge aux
médecines alternatives à la naturopathie
on retrouve encore les anthroposophes
dans les grandes manifestations avec des
avec des masques blancs qui eux qui se
sont multipliées pendant les les
confinements successifs cette ce type de
manifestation a été créée par des
parents en école steiner et donc on voit
une espèce de convergence surprenante
entre ce mouvement plutôt réactionnaire
et ce mouvement plus tôt
on va dire papa progressisme et qui se
rattache plutôt à l'écologie
historiquement qui vont converger autour
de d'un discours de la sacralité du
corps de la supériorité absolue de la
nature sur la science sur la sur la
médecine est finalement un rejet un peu
tous azimuts de la modernité vous
l'évoquiez les religions un terreau pour
les dérives sectaires on en parle tout
de suite on fait une petite pause on
revient à tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
et on est de retour sur le plateau de la
grande interview pour parler de dérive
sectaire avec nos invités jean loup
adenor timothée de rauglaudre alors on
parlait des petits gros à l'instant
favorable à ces dérives secteur il y à
l'univers de la religion bien évidemment
on va parler de la religion catholique
est concerné mais également l'islam vous
êtes intéressé finalement à ces dérives
qui ont été traités par l'état français
parlé l'antiterrorisme or au départ
c'était la miviludes ce qui était chargé
de la lutte contre les sectes qui sont
chargés ou en tout cas l'organe alors
minutes contrôle et celles qui s'en
charge raconte en fait c'est qu'on a
pris le parti pour ce chapitre sur sur
l'islam de raconter cette montée de
l'islamisme et du jihadisme que ça
concerne partie commandes janice mme à
l'époque qui a été vu perçue d'abord par
des associations de lutte contre les
dérives sectaires et qui en fait vont
elles l'analyser sous le prisme de la
dérive sectaire et ont par la suite les
services de renseignement français vont
effectivement s'y intéresser ça va
devenir une affaire qui va concerner
uniquement de renseignement et on va
sortir cette question là la question de
l'emprise sectaire mais ce qui était
intéressant dans ce travail là c'était
de montrer que pour les personnes qui
voient le phénomène monte en fait toutes
les cases qu'elles ont l'habitude de
cocher quand l analyse un témoignage
vont être cochée donc on a effectivement
le témoignage dans notre notre livre de
seth de cette mère qui voit sa fille
sombré de plus en plus dans une pratique
pour le mentaliste de l'islam qui va
finir par partir en syrie avec ses
enfants et son mari qui est internet
evangelist
cette mère va vraiment nous décrire un
phénomène d'auriga tu m'emm également
sectaire en fait et ça a été l'occasion
pour nous de montrer que en fait quel
que soit le discours religieux voire la
visée politique de d'un mouvement
l'impact
l'impact sur la personne va souvent être
semblable en fait quand on passe de des
témoins de jéhovah aux islamistes en
passant par certains groupes par
certains groupes catholiques on va
retrouver le même le même domaine
d'emprise la même abolition des pensées
critiques la même rupture avec la
famille les mêmes détournement des
circuits financiers parce qu'ils vont
notamment financé des groupes des
groupes terroristes djihadistes avec
l'argent de l'état a parfois des aides
sociales et compagnie donc c'est certain
nombre de critères qu'on retrouve dans
dans toutes ces dérives et qui n'ont pas
été traités comme tels par par le
gouvernement finalement ces dernières
années alors il y avait eu une tentative
sous la présidence de françois hollande
avec
l'anthropologue dounia bouzar qui
avaient été critiqués pour
leurs raisons mais en tout cas il y
avait eu cette tentative de d'envisager
le l'islam radical sous le prisme
sectaire et il semble que ça a été un
petit peu
laissé de côté ces dernières années on
raconte notamment une des conséquences
du rattachement de la minute de
ministère de l'intérieur c'est que la
miviludes avait un chercheur qui était
collaborateur en tant que contractuels
de la miviludes spécialisés sur ces
question d'islam radical et qui avait
notamment produit une étude passionnante
sur sur la roquille acquis et le la
version musulmane de l'exorcisme et là
il jama qui est une forme de médecine
dite prophétique donc il avait montré
les connexions avec avec l'emprise
sectaire et son contrat n'a pas été
renouvelé il devait y avoir une étude
plus large qui n'a pas été menée parce
qu'en fait les moyens de la miviludes
sont en baisse rappelons juste en
passant il ya quelque chose d'important
à comprendre pour ça c'est que le
phénomène d'emprise on connaît enfin on
commence à le connaître on a des
critères on sait on sait plus ou moins
comment identifier une emprise et le
phénomène de déprise donc la sortie
d'emprise c'est quelque chose qu'on
maîtrise très mal finalement j'ai envie
dire peu importe que la radicalisation
soient pris sous le prisme de la dérive
sectaire ou pas la question c'est est-ce
que ce prisme là permet d'agir
différemment et permettrait de sortir
des gens de cette emprise là et la
réalité c'est que on a vu l'expérience
qui a été menée par dounia bouzar on
voit que faire sortir quelqu'un d'une
emprise sectaire c'est très difficile et
on ne sait pas encore très bien comment
faire aimer et vous même dans votre
enquête vous avez eu des difficultés à
recueillir des témoignages parce que ça
ne va pas être évident pour ces
personnes de d'échangés alors qu'elles
sortent tout juste une emprise ou
qu'elles le sont peut être encore
d'ailleurs bien sûr on a sur la
trentaine de témoignages qu'on a
recueilli on en a qu'une poignée qui
témoigne sous leurs sous leur nom
complet la plupart sont anonymes soit
par par peur des représailles puisqu'il
peut y avoir des violences
des violences de certains groupes sur
les réseaux sociaux voire voir en
physique et
il ya aussi une volonté de tourner la
page de passer à autre chose qui est
tout à fait légitime parce que le la
pire chose qui puisse arriver à une
victime de dérives sectaires c'est
qu'une fois qu'elle est sorti du groupe
elle se retrouve un petit peu à signer à
vie à mener le combat contre 7 ce
mouvement est en fait tu n'arrives pas à
se reconstruire sa propre vie ses
propres valeurs ses propres horizons à
l'écart de ce mouvement là on parlait
tout à l'heure de la proximité
de certaines mouvance sectaire avec
certains membres du gouvernement il ya
l'église catholique ou si vous la
raconter très bien qu'il ya un terreau
un terrain de jeu idéal finalement pour
les gourous et yahia là aussi des
proximités qui se forme vous le dites
vous l'expliquer dans votre livre oui
c'est assez intéressant parce que en
fait historiquement il ya deux groupes
sociaux qui ont été précurseurs dans la
lutte contre les dérives sectaires c'est
d'abord des familles catholiques qui
voyaient leurs enfants partir par
exemple dans le dans l'église du
révérend moon et de l'autre côté plutôt
des militants de la gauche laïque donc
ça a donné les deux principales
associations historiques n'est de
l'unadfi et le ccmm et petit à petit en
fait on s'est rendu compte que au sein
même de l'église catholique il y avait
des groupes d des figures qui pouvaient
exercer une emprise sectaire de la même
manière que des groupes new age ou la
scientologie etc figure très populaire
très charismatique d'ailleurs absolument
et notamment autour de ce qu'on a appelé
les communautés nouvelles qui après le
concile vatican ii ont proliféré dans
l'église et qui ont été soutenues
notamment par jean paul ii dans le cadre
de la nouvelle évangélisation dans le
but de redynamiser une église en perte
de en perte de fidèles tout simplement
et souvent dans ces communautés
le
le message s'est construit autour d'une
figure charismatique donc dit ayant un
charisme c'est à dire une connexion
directe direct avec dieu avec une
confusion des pouvoirs c'est à dire que
le leader pouvait être à la fois le
confesseur le responsable administratif
du groupe et c'est une concentration des
pouvoirs qui normalement est réprimée
par le par le droit canonique et donc
nous on donne deux exemples de
communauté la première c'est ces points
coeur qui est petit se présente comme
une ong humanitaire qui a été construit
fondée par un prêtre thierry de roucy
condamné d'ailleurs condamnée par par
l'église d'absolument
accusé de
d'agression sexuelle mais non documente
sur toulalan prises qui s'exerce sur les
adeptes et et on parle d'une autre
communauté un peu moins connus qui
s'appelle la fraternité eucharistein
créé par le suisse
nicolas buttet donc qui a notamment qui
notamment
prétend guérir un peu tout et n'importe
quoi par des exorcismes dans un cadre
pareil là qui sort complètement du cadre
donné par l'elysée comme une institution
assez assez régulier et centralisée
et ce qui est intéressant c'est dans ces
deux mouvements il ya eu en fait des des
soutiens alors on sait pas si c'est des
soutiens un peu naïf au ou ou des
soutiens complaisant mais par exemple le
cariste n a été financée par la famille
bettencourt la famille mulliez en fait
des donateurs qui pensent faire
peut-être oeuvres de charité mais ferme
les yeux sur l'emprise qui peut exister
au sein de ces groupes alors c'est vrai
que les dérives sectaires dans les
religions c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaissait les les grandes règles vous
parliez de moon l'église de la
scientologie là encore en revanche ce
qu'on découvre aussi dans votre livre
c'est qu'il ya des villages entiers ya
notamment un village qui est
complètement sous emprise comment est ce
que vous avez découvert ce phénomène
vous êtes rendus sur place racontez nous
alors c'est vrai qu'on a en effet rendu
avait gagné sur place avec avec timothée
qui voit par là je pense que je pense
mieux que moi mais on s'y est vendu sous
dans un moment qui était particulier
puisqu'on était en pleine pandémie et
qu'on s'est retrouvé dans ce village
dans un autre temps à votre moment en
fait parce qu'on avait l'impression de
la pandémie n'existait pas à cet endroit
là et je les laissais timothée raconter
ce
week end en fait parce qu'on a passé
trois jours là bah oury bah en fait
c'est nous on avait été alertée par une
ancienne habitante
qui a vécu un an dans ce village qui se
présente comme un comme un éco village
avec du marc du maraîchage bio un
système de recyclage de l'eau etc mais
qui en fait 10 nuls là encore de une
espèce de concentration de de newedge de
médecine parallèle avec une forte
présence de l'anthroposophie donc on
s'est rendu sur place et effectivement
il y avait ce discours vis-à-vis de la
pandémie qui était assez
qui était assez interpellant
le virus fait mal surtout à ceux qui y
croient 20 ce genre de discours
une espèce de convergence voilà entre
entre complotisme ésotérisme et rejet de
la médecine conventionnelle et on vous
regarde bizarrement là bas rhin fait pas
partie en gagnant nous regardent bizarre
parce qu'on porte des masques que parce
qu'on a l'air très très urbain et puis
parce que c'est des gens qui se
connaissent et qui est l'un des tout
petits et tout petits hameaux donc
effectivement quand vous venez de
l'extérieur vous êtes soit vous venez
parce que vous êtes recommandé par
quelqu un au cou a vu le conseille
d'aller là pour une raison qui est bien
précise à savoir vivre différemment soit
vous êtes touristes et vous n'êtes pas
au courant auquel cas on vous regarde on
prend un peu des pincettes on a quand
même réussi à parler avec des gens qui
nous ont expliqué un peu quelles étaient
leurs leur leurs idées en s'installant
ici il ya beaucoup ce côté de 2 oui
c'est ça de recréer un environnement qui
échappe aux règles de la république au
discours sur la vaccination mais c'est
un phénomène qui je pense est en est en
expansion en fait on le voit on a vu la
nacion qui a essayé de s'installer dans
le lot de mémoire ou alors je confonds
peut-être à sehnaya que je crois que
ouanna jeunesse et de s'installer nation
précisé nouvelle nation c'est un groupe
alors qu'il n'est pas très honnête on ne
voit pas pour l'instant de dérives
sectaires à proprement parler mais c'est
un groupe qui entend vivre hors des
règles de la république qui entend
renoncer à la nation prononcé à l'école
donc on est sur un sécessionnisme
séparatisme pour reprendre les termes
utilisés par le par le gouvernement mais
qui est clair qui est qui est conscient
qu'ils essaient une idéologie consciente
voilà et c'est notamment le groupe dans
lequel était la mère de la petite mia a
été enlevé par
alors qui a été enlevée qui a été enlevé
par un groupe qui serait proche de rémy
daillet selon les informations qui sont
sortis dans la presse cette année et y
en a d'autres des groupes comme ça on
voit que reinfo qu'ovide je vous envoie
je vous renvoie l enquête de william
audureau qui est ce groupe qui a fait de
la réinformation en tout cas d
information alternative
et défèquent news sur le col vide
également essayé de s'installer de créer
un hameau un village pour vivre entre
eux et sans avoir à se vacciner ou donc
on voit que c'est un phénomène qui qui à
notre sens c'est vraiment plus de
vitesse il nous reste quelques minutes
encore on arrive au terme de cette
émission néanmoins à ce que vous avez eu
des retours sur votre enquête je pense
notamment aux politiques aux
responsables alors on a eu des retours
sur notre enquête du milieu associatif
et des gens qui je sais pas s'il faut
dire me dit mais en tout cas qui se sont
engagés dans la dans la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires qui nous alerte sur
leurs inquiétudes on a commencé ce
travail peu avant le coded à un moment
où les gens parler assez peu de
l'emprise sectaire et où la miviludes
était menacé de disparition selon les
informations qu'on avait à l'époque
aujourd'hui le comité passée par là là
le phénomène sectaire est en explosion
s'est documenté on est des alertes
vraiment très très régulière sur ce
phénomène un peu partout en france on
voi ce que je vous raconte l instant le
phénomène de deux d'isolement en tout
cas de conquête de certains une certaine
partie du territoire donc il ya des gags
l'inquiétude et dans le même temps on se
rend compte que l'outil qu'on avait mis
en place dans les années 90 donc la
miviludes cet outil unique au monde
français qui permettait justement de
repérer lutter lui est très abîmé on
nous promet des moyens pour la miviludes
nous de ce qu'on a comme information il
n'y a pas de moyens particuliers qui ont
été mis sur la table la ministre mme
aïcha pas effectivement attribuées un
million d'euros aux associations sur
appel à projet c'est juste une
association en a besoin parce qu'elles
sont elles sont quand même plutôt
exemple ont besoin de cet argent là mais
en terme de
d'annoncer réel sur l'action des
pouvoirs publics est pour l'instant on
n'a pas et on demande à voir oui on fait
ce qu'on documente aussi dans le livre
c'est le recul de l'intérêt des pouvoirs
publics et plus largement des élites
pour le phénomène sectaire et on espère
que pendant la campagne présidentielle
dure à des prises de parole deux des
candidats sur cette question là pour
l'instant c'est pas du tout le cas à
l'exception je crois de jean luc
mélenchon qui en a parlé sur sur france
culture mais emmanuel macron n'a jamais
prononcé publiquement le mot secte ou
enfin sectaire on n'emploie pas le mot
secte mais n'a jamais parlé du phénomène
sectaire ouvertement en amour vous avez
eu des pressions des mouvements
sectaires dépression non on a eu on a
faim de travail qui est qui est assez
rigoureux on a fait du contradictoire on
les a prévenus on a on a eu des
réactions très virulentes à un moment
pour la poser des questions mais une
fois que les questions ont été posées on
a recueilli leurs contradictoires et on
a avancé donc à ce jour n'a pas eu pour
l'instant de pression particulière un
grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
jean-loup adenor timothée de roux l'oms
rappelle votre livre le nouveau péril
sectaire aux éditions robert laffont à
cette grande interview est à revoir sur
notre site internet air france point tv
à écouter également en podcast à très
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]